hey reject nation greg alba here I'm cat
Alvarado Chad Alvarado hey cat you know
what I think we should do what before we
go into this try not to laugh challenge
what we should mention that on Friday
night at nine p.m. March 23rd you don't
have to try not to laugh cuz you're
gonna want to laugh anyway on the FNX
Channel 9 p.m. March 23rd cata morado is
gonna be on television
yeah the First Nations comedy experience
show that's what a sense for dad's First
Nations got me experience it's a Native
American channel a Native American a
little bit that counts qualifies you to
do comedy on their Channel you guys
should go check your local listings and
make sure that you have the FNX Channel
I'm gonna buy it only $150 a month the
part down there thanks for clarifying
with the know all right well Kat
straight face time don't laugh do not Oh
God and if you do laugh just start again
it's not a real challenge but people
love watching these anyway
[Music]
[Music]
whoa it's not funny at all
[Music]
from the brain
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's your name me yes you I am me it's
me and I'm you and I'm not
[Music]
whoa that real
[Music]
[Music]
culture
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
damn damn I'm so trying not to laugh at
that right now people say I look like
him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
whoa
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay let me just start by saying I
appreciate the editing and the time and
the effort that went in to this
compilation a for effort a lot of hard
work there a lot of hard work yes I
think we have seen some try not to
laughs where there are some real
struggles to not laugh yes some of these
were just like shocking or whoa
or like that was adorable yeah we're
like ouch that looking full but most of
some like it was the person who edited
this laughing I think the thing that
like some of the other try not to laughs
get right is the timing and the contrast
of what's happening and like it has to
be really huge change and happen right
when you least expect it it's more than
just a compilation of just pudding I
would like to experiment with the
transyl a video like try to create my
own yeah interesting because there is a
timing to the editing that creates the
laughter to try to get someone there
it's more than just the piling footage
together it might seem like that when
you watch certain ones but that's the
whole point of the flawless editing like
the guy with the this baby and then it
like closes smoke I'm like that's really
cool and then do two catches the
baseball like that's really cool yeah I
mean that one's kind of funny when he's
like surfing and then gets the guy off
the jetski like funny to an
eight-year-old like a lot of these
things maybe an eight-year-old wouldn't
yeah I don't know but you're
professional comedian who's on the FNX
Channel this Friday 9:00 p.m. Pacific
Standard Time well let you just left the
boobs right that's just for my own
entertainment why don't we they get a
little screen shot here for a little
Greggy earlier I'm at the editing
station well look of actual pornography
I got cleavage shot here
but yeah I mean still funny so
entertaining I was amused throughout so
you gotta give credit where credit's due
I think the funniest one for me okay
funniest - or the fart Justin Bieber
that's the kind of comedy you'll get on
the FNX Channel this Friday the Filipino
look Filipino he might not have been
Filipino but the Asian man with the
breathalyzer tests and that one guy that
one got me the one that I was kind of
getting me was a little kid with the
leaf blower who was freaking out over
the power yeah because I remember being
a little kid thinking like this is a
powerful thing this leaf blower this is
adorable compilation I appreciate it
still regardless who is this channel
make God bless you for all your sins
funny land funny land all right funny
land great trying to laugh challenge for
children I think we're the first people
to ever criticize a the wave of comments
of these really negative we have no
sense of humor it's really operated we
just start talking French accents
because French people are very negative
and very critical taking an improv class
[Laughter]
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification will get
notified every time a video of ours is
up get Alvarado as on social media FNX
Channel this Friday March 23rd make sure
to catch her on your local television 9
p.m. and follow me at the cat Alvarado
on Twitter or Instagram
you